hey god bless you dr. Wallach very kind
thank you how can I help you today
oh my brother has had a series of
strokes her first one was about twelve
thirty years ago then she had another
beta stroke 2015 and then she just had
one and talked to the time be given up
order she's like all over easily twenty
medications you know how much she weigh
and how old is she she's probably about
220 pounds she's 56 years old scoliosis
rheumatory arthritis it's just some deep
problems any problems also yes okay now
turn to encounter how tall is she she's
about fun to came on five to I would say
she's probably a hundred and ten pounds
overweight she needs to cut her weight
in half five foot two okay so what would
you do here for ever's mom here sharp
she has a knee problem she's had several
strokes was it her um well she needs she
needs to take two healthy I would give
her two healthy brain and heart packs
and then she needs to add the gluco gel
to that probably fifteen or twenty a day
and she needs to add the killer biotic
okay would you give her for the weight
loss the rather core either yep and so
you know she's the one who would need
two bottles a month to the Rev a dropper
full under her tongue thirty minutes for
each meal the second dropper 400-some
fifteen minutes for each meal let absorb
it through a rotation don't let her
swallow it the killer body guide hair
take anywhere from six to nine of those
a days and I go for nine if this is
inflammatory and really is swollen and
hurts the strokes are actually caused by
deficiency of a single nutrient if their
blood clots types of strokes and so the
two healthy brain and heart packs are
perfect because she's going to get two
forms that new trends in each one and so
she could have three of the EFA plus as
a breakfast and dinner and three of the
aphasia breakfast and dinner and then
what would you give her that has enzymes
in it they're legendary for dissolving
blood clots
I well the niacin plus has got the nano
kinase Center okay yeah I give her two
bottles of the niacin Plus says you can
take two of those capsules at breakfast
it's dinner time in addition to having a
time-release non-flush niacin which
helps dilate blood pressures and sudra
dilate blood vessels use me and but it
also has nano kinase in it again which
is legendary are dissolving blood clots
and so that's kind of direction I would
go and showers exactly right
on the basic program and including
weight loss and so give us a call every
couple of weeks to do whatever it let us
know mom's blood pressure is what she
weighs let us know how things are going
with her knee and her other joints are
back and so forth and let us know too if
you know she's beginning to show signs
of improvement from some of the residual
symptoms of the stroke